1378 kilometer australien mit singapore
airlines täglich im airbus a380 ab
zürich
[Musik]
wow
die aus pashmina 106 8 schlossen
bis zu dem zeitpunkt hat wird er nun als
musterstadt gold über die verarbeiter
angelockte
cem medien familien in modernen familie
klappt aber auch in der wolke
verfinstert phase wie fielmann scheine
sport voll geständig umstritten
neugierig herüber und zur sperrzone
deklariert warum trägst du eine maske
brauche ich die nicht nein sonst würde
ich nicht hier leben glaubst du etwa der
regierung
ich habe nur die warnschilder gesehen
es gibt in den modernen minen mehr als
pest als hier
was halten sie von der regierung
das wirst du nicht wirklich wissen
ich glaube nicht an die theorie der
regierung dass es hier ein
gesundheitsrisiko
ich habe alle untersuchungsberichte und
dokumente der regierung
und solange die beweisen dass es in den
modernen eisenerzminen mehr asbestfasern
gibt als hier bleibe ich kam wegen des
wunderbaren wetter niemand bringt
[Musik]
florian hat noch genau die nachbarn ganz
oben an der dorfstraße und romario der
technolit raum vertrieben
[Musik]
bereits für das zufügen
du musst mario sein
bist du hier aufgewachsen und wo kommst
du deutsch sprechen ja sehr gut das
kommt mir entgegen
also voll ist und vom team kommt das
dritte für kundige wie mich etwa mario
zwei blocks aus bereit mit einer will
anzeige
das alles nicht so gefährlich ist wenn
man sein aber das ist das ist aber das
war den start und boden die sich nicht
ich nicht wirklich erholen also was
nicht sie ist also die ganz viele frauen
diese spiele für das heißt eigentlich
was im steinig und dürfte keine angst
wir da muss schaefer mit dem zug ist und
wie wichtig die hand ja aber wie lange
bist jetzt hier lernen entwickeln und
nur okay
mario siebig sagen gesund dies galt als
wetterfrosch vermitteln
in 287 stück vorarlbergern als tourist
hier verwirrung a40 in die gegend und
blieb dort aber der ist ja wirklich und
schlager völker an in hongkong am
sonntag aus der heimat hat bordeaux ist
sie wirklich
er wurde also entwicklung oder blüte und
rollout und die mhh solartechnik
software nach einer rettung
damit verspricht wetterstation
temperaturen wo er sich den weg zwischen
der luftfeuchtigkeit ja ein maximum
minimum durch die am morgen
durch diese habe für die nächsten 24
stunden
ok und die frage wieviel strahlung und
die herrschte hier je nach wetter nun
verfügt oder oder oder
warum also das heißt de hier kann
erklärt ja an welchen bern für ist ein
dorf gange also das heißt sich die
rohstoffe den ersten blick also das ist
eigentlich mehr einiges motor hier in
witten um mentale miteinanders und noch
mal zusammen
[Musik]
mario hartmann der riesige kontinent
offen gestanden hat sich aber in der
sperrzone entscheiden
seit wochen schinkel ford reagierte sie
gelacht so ganz zufällig
[Musik]
westküste entlang fahren nach exmouth
foto größter listening galerie essig
mischen sie so schön mit great barrier
reef und noch viel bessere
[Musik]
ich habe mich für meeresbiologie danny
webb abgemacht geschafft für
nationalparkbehörde von ingelore hüft-op
schutz vor der riesige walheim rief
laden
pünktlich zum sonnenuntergang
ja das ist unser lieblingsplatz hier
oben wir haben bereits einige male
gesehen
sie sind vorbei geschwommen von hier
oben
toll und dazu barbecue mit freunden und
familie
ja wir treffen uns zu garnelen und
champagner und halten ausschau nach den
beinen
ich bin hungrig nach der langen fahrt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die demiri glaube sie am nächsten morgen
betreut begleitet und mit blick
verschwimmt
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen liegt vor der küste
einige ausflugsboot in aix muss endlich
in der letzten jahr einige touristen
name oft für marketing von der wahrheit
spezialisiert
konkurrenz unter den touristen boot ist
groß umso wichtiger sind kontrolle
die denic begleitet regelmäßig weilheims
flick und kontrolliert ob die richtlinie
karte war
jedes boot größten lizenz und ist auch
eine strikte verhaltenskodex umgestellt
[Musik]
obwohl zeug zum schutz vor der
australischen
oberstes ziel von emmi ist der schutz
vor der wahrheit
der captain von touristenboot will mit
der vermarktung von der ha ja geld
verdienen
die dänischen papier kontrolliert ich
stehe mit locker und freundschaftlich
der bus ist aber die denn wenn sie
unregelmäßigkeiten bezüglich richtlinie
entdeckt riskierte frau stellte die
lizenz zu verlieren
langsam spielers liblar des flugzeugs
war heuer und mit dem captain die genaue
position
[Musik]
wir sportler mir serie holte der dörfer
ist imho nur verhindern sodass er
ungehindert hobbys schwimmen und wir
müssen einen mindestabstand von 4 mio
[Musik]
nur ein paar wenige meter von mir weg
der walhai nicht kritisch angemerkt
praktisch kurz mit einer einzigen
flossenschlag dort riss ab in dunkelheit
vom indischen ozean
[Musik]
60 bei uns gut
hätte ich so schnell und sicher dass
optionen ist ohnehin nichts entschieden
endlich über berichten
ja ich habe ihn gesehen aber nur kurz
war wohl ein schneller kern
er hat ziemlich schnell das flugzeug hat
schon einen langsameren entdeckt wir
fahren zudem
bolhaar sind einzelgänger und wandert
entlang die denn überwacht dass die
touristen boden nichts langweiliger dir
blieben
der captain muss immer wieder andere
haustiere maschine half dem flugzeug
erspart
wann hast du deinen ersten mal gesehen
vor etwa zehn jahren und das war der
moment in dem du dich in die tiere
verliebt hat diese tiere haben mich
schon in der schule fasziniert aber ich
hätte mir nie erträumt als sich der
einstige lief mit ihnen arbeiten werde
als zwölfjährige konnte ich mir das
nicht vorstellen es ist fantastisch ich
finde sie sind mehr wale als haie
nein das meinen alle es sind richtige
heyer und nicht mit dem wall verwandt
aber der charakter scheint so hoch wenn
wir sie sehen sind sie nicht auf
nahrungssuche
sie wärmen sich gemütlich an der
meeresoberfläche auf ich habe die wahl
hat ja schon in gefräßiger ekstase
erlebt wenn sie hungrig waren sie
schießen mit offenem maul das wasser
dann wirst du auf keinen fall in ihrer
nähe sein
nicht weil sie angreifen würden aber sie
sind so schnell und kräftig du könntest
ihnen kaum ausreichen
ein zweiter bohrer ist dort rügen dreht
er seine runden
die große
[Musik]
obwohl war ja so imposant sind weiß man
sehr wenig relevant route und die
response verhalten
die denic vermutet dass sie ein großer
teil von ihrem lover in großer der finne
verringert meeresbiologen und jetzt auch
etwas wie wild los fotografieren die ich
spiele jeden der individuell die
training kadir identifizieren und so die
population kontrollieren
[Musik]
vier meter linie sagen so schön sein
extrem niedrig
wie alle faszination und begeistert mir
das okay ist
kommst du nochmals rein nein ok nein mir
ist schlecht
ich behalte doch in bar und nicht
wirklich seetauglich minijob ich hoffe
und ich träume verworrenheit
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen ich mich erholt
inzwischen stand 11 30 400
trainingskilometer offenthaler weiter
geht's entlang vor der westküste
[Musik]
es herrsche reger generellen gewachsen
und wir sehr nett gehört
frage scharf angegriffen
[Musik]
wir drehen ein reise sicher kann ich
dich interview
ab jetzt gebaut
du bist der franzose und du bist mit dem
fahrrad unterwegs
ja ich mache eine weltreise wo bist du
losgefahren
ich bin schon von paris nach darwin
gefahren
letztes jahr machte ich kerns bissigen
da hast du aber was vor
was hast du alles dabei nahrungsmittel
und kochutensilien bleibt zeug fürs
fahrrad schlafsack klein
das ist ein solarpanel für den computer
und dem kleinen rucksacks und alle
wertsachen und wo schläfst du wenn du
müde bist du einfach du fährst von der
straße darunter hinter den nächsten
busch vorstellst einfach dein zelt auf
dann wünsche ich dir viel glück für
seine weltreise und macht keinen unfall
habe mich in rotwein erwischt macht der
kleinholz aus
was sind das für manche strecken der vor
sicherheit so unglaublich nämlich
relativ stark auf sie
[Musik]
zum sohn jong-un nächsten morgen
erreichen die berühmte pinnacles
[Musik]
2001 fast zehnjährige zeit ist versteh
unterwasserlandschaft
der held wenn wir sein rief der spitze
aus dem boden ragen
die rollstühle sind vor dieser vorjahren
standen dazu die stadt sachlich alters
unerwartet
[Musik]
dazu geben wird
langsam matches mini reiste menzel ich
besitze zwei monate unterwegs
also bilder nämlich mit und die blieben
unvergessen
ich frage mich wie warten manche gefragt
war so ein los schienen der landschaft
über boxen
familie heimat keine die geborgenheit
gebettet in der hohenberger
[Musik]
ich weise wieder richtig durch bevor ich
aber eine großstadt lande machen
das land gehört touristen für freie kost
und logis ich einen gasofen idee kommen
ganz australien begegnet so genannt
[Musik]
ich wandere ihnen dabei im hang und das
sieht nach arbeit ist
wegen abkürzens willing workers organic
farms direkt übersetzt willige arbeiter
oft biopharma als cleveres konzept wobei
die siebte seinen profitieren objekte
kommen so zu billige arbeitskraft und
die meistens junge touristen kennen die
das reisebudget schonen
hallo ich bin's wende freut mich dich
kennenzulernen sandy lucy sarah und
julia italien und frankreich haben schon
einige buche hier und schaffen vier bis
sechs stunden pro tag seien die zehn ist
immer gleichzeitig als la kröm wurde wie
vor ihrem rat pack die und sind die voll
was muss angreifer kann der alles was er
können muss lernt er bei uns reben
schneiden flaschen abfüllen kleinere
bauarbeiten aber es ist schon wichtig
dass es gute handwerker sind aber
studenten könnte wohl nicht brauchen
wenn sie lernwillig sind schon es geht
vor allem um das erlebnis hier auf der
farm und nicht darum als experte für uns
zu arbeiten
giuseppe und sarah zum beispiel haben
schon einige erfahrung mitgebracht und
machen das wirklich gut wäre es ohne die
hofer schwierig für euch ja wir haben
beide noch unsere jobs in der stadt
allein werden wir die arbeit hier nie
schaffen
mit vorne neuen strömen regnet erledigen
wir wie vor zählt mehr als wir wissen
[Musik]
das verzeichnis von der formel 2 5 namen
ist es so dick wie ein telefonbuch
sandy und ihrer ehemann peter betrieben
das land gehörten im jahr
beide schaffen aber immer noch ihre
angestammte prüfen
russland gehört
[Musik]
der mann der ihn flugs sein die unter
peter beliefern der lokalen früchte
[Musik]
dieser
da werden
[Musik]
mittwoch
und so fruchtig sehr gut
wo verschaffe mindestens 1 monat und
häkchens halbes jahr auf dem land gehört
sie erledigen die wendige handarbeit war
10 die am papier regularien nikrandt ii
finanziert
julia warum hast du dich für australien
weil es einfach ist ein ferien arbeits
visum zu bekommen
der lebensstil ist locker die menschen
sind offen
mein bruder war auch schon in australien
und hat geschwärmt
ein tolles erlebnis und was meinst du
ist australien das lucky country
ja ich finde schon als australierin
würde es mich stolz machen dass so viele
menschen aus der ganzen welt mein land
kennenlernen und hier erfahrungen
sammeln ein glückliches land ja
nach dem anderen produziert das land
gehört wie ich lebe der friesen die
canon der petri schenkel bauunternehmer
und ingenieure wie sie im australischen
winter abermals einschnitte waren pass
einfach auf das du dir nicht die
software liegt rief abschnitte warten
und weil im frühling seinen betrieb du
bist bau unternehmer und ingenieur hier
auf der farm machst du mein indikation
es ist eine flucht aus der stadt wegen
der lebensqualität könnt ihr von den
mann der ihn lieben
nein ich arbeite immer noch auf meinem
beruf die farmer haben wir wirklich nur
für den lebensstil und die abwechslung
früher glaubte ich ich müsste auswandern
um ein ruhiges plätzchen zu finden
dann entdeckte ich zufällig dieses
grundstück wurde klar ich muss
australien gar nicht verlassen um genau
das zu finden was ich suche es ist so
ein großes land und zu vielfältig kannst
gleichzeitig in einem ende skifahren und
am anderen mit walheim schnorcheln
ich habe mein glück gefunden mitten in
westaustralien
mancher wieder peter eine offene reisen
betroffen
wir sind stolz so viel das land und
zeigen dass mit ihrer gastfreundschaft
während die gäste ganz waldler bei einer
an ihrem lucky country sandy und
petersson jeder aber gemeinsam mit ihrem
ufer sie teilen die das labor mit ihnen
bisher demonstriert raffinesse
vertrauliche unkompliziert und
sympathisch
im himmel
[Musik]
familie recherchereise aber nicht alle
ausländer werden in australien so
herzlich empfangen wie ich auf dem land
gehört vor der sendung vom bieten
[Musik]
so nirgendwo ist der volkssport sie und
ich mit der viktoria komischer
treffpunkt am straßenrand bist du bereit
für das abenteuer ist es weit weg von
hier
fünf oder zehn minuten hast du deinen
ausweis dabei fahrausweis
identitätskarte pass alles dabei und wie
gesagt keine kameras keine hände ich die
jungs freuen sich schon auf den besuch
[Musik]
viktoria martin schöpferin organisation
naschi vertrag vor der flüchtling
gesetzt
australier hat in äußerst restriktive
asylpolitik in europa im mittelmeer
streunender hier in australien diesige
verbots flüchtlinge mehr verwischt wird
landet ihm eine sogenannte detention
center was ist ein detention center es
ist eine geschlossene einrichtung in der
asylsuchende inhaftiert werden ohne
anklage und prozess
sie bleiben oft für lange zeit
eingesperrt
viktoria besucht regelmäßig flüchtling
in detention center und hilft ihnen
ich gebe mich als kolleg vor ihre aus
und bekomme also eine general
journalisten und fernsehkameras
verschlossen blieb
[Musik]
in jonah hill land 500 asylbewerber
mit die restriktive ausländerpolitik
welt regiert flüchtling abschrecken und
sicherstellen dass nie ändert eure wenn
der asylantrag abgelehnt wird
[Musik]
juristisch fertig mancher kann erklärt
war mir ihre tragische geschichte
erzählt heimat geflüchtet
und sind hier im lucky country in der
dreifachen starken zyklen wird einige
sitzen bis zu drei jahren
[Musik]
die sicherheitsstandards im detention
center sind unglaublich wie im gefängnis
so will die regierung der bevölkerung
weismachen flüchtlinge müssten
eingesperrt werden die infrastruktur ist
teil der botschaft für leute wie mich
für familienmitglieder und freunde sind
asylsuchende normale menschen wie du und
ich
sie sind nicht kriminell im gegenteil
sie sind besonders verletzlich tapfer
und mutig die regierung sagt aber dies
seien wirtschaftsflüchtlinge die nicht
vor einem krieg fliehen mussten
fakt ist und das belegen die offiziellen
zahlen der regierung 90 prozent der
menschen die per boot ankommen sind
anerkannte flüchtlinge
es ist propaganda und es ist eine lüge
wenn die regierung behauptet dies seien
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge
wir haben einen mann getroffen der
taliban kugeln in seinem körper hat ganz
klar ein überlebender eines massakers
die regierung sagt geht zurück in deine
heimat
wir können uns glücklich schätzen dass
diese flüchtlinge nach australien kommen
sie erinnern uns daran was es heißt
freundlich anständig und großzügig zu
sein wenn mehr menschen diese werte
teilen kann australien wieder das
glücklicher land für uns alle sein
ich will nicht in einer gesellschaft
leben die es in ordnung findet menschen
zu bestrafen weil sie asyl suchen
was wäre denn die lösung schafft die
detention center ab machen wir es so wie
früher so wie viele andere länder auch
dass die flüchtlinge in freiheit leben
bis ihre asylanträge bearbeitet sind
sie sollen unter uns leben
während all ihre papiere geprüft werden
wir zerstören menschen leben in diesen
einrichtungen schutz vor gewalt von
lucky country wirklichen drei wochen
stocherte
[Musik]
in perth psychischer emotionale der
afghanischen center von brünn vor einem
tag auf den anderen
hermine ist heiterem himmel in
australien willkommen kaiser china
asylantrag ich gehörte wusste
erinnerst du dich an deinen ersten tag
in australien
das war der sechzehnte august 2000 wir
mussten uns in reih und glied aufstellen
der name verlor bist du was afghanistan
ich heiße aiden journal
okay das ist eine nummer von diesem tag
an während drei jahren im detention
center sagte kein betreuer mir meinen
namen
ich war nur noch eine nummer
wenn man die eine nummer klebt ist eine
sache die ein abfalleimer oder ein
küchentisch keine gefühle das ist
furchtbar hunde hier in australien haben
[Musik]
aber wir flüchtlinge hatten nummern
seine familie kam nach hause
[Musik]
frei von ncr ich mit lina an mir im kino
xxi australien das glückliche land ist
es auch für flüchtlinge das lucky
country nur wenn sie nicht in die
taschen zu interessant nachdem detention
center kannst du glücklich werden weil
der viele chancen offen stehen
vor allem bei bildung und beruf es ist
friedlich hier darum heißt es
wahrscheinlich lucky country weil du
viele möglichkeiten im leben begonnen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das sind
wie reagierten deine freunde als du
einen flüchtling geheiratet hast sie
sehen ihn nicht als flüchtling er ist
einfach an die flucht ist nur ein teil
von ihm
ich bin nicht mit einem flüchtling
verheiratet aber er war ein flüchtling
ja aber das ist nicht seine identität er
ist allem er hatte eine schwierige zeit
aber er ist deswegen nicht für immer dem
der flüchtling
aber es gibt natürlich menschen in
australien die ganz andere ansichten zu
den flüchtlingen haben als ich aber wenn
sie einen flüchtling kennenlernen seine
geschichte hören bekommen sie eine
persönliche beziehung und einen anderen
zugang zum thema
[Musik]
reden ist voll integriert er schafft
eine öffentliche schule war sich um
flüchtlingskinder kümmert keiner weise
so gehört wie matschie durchgemacht hat
[Musik]
die bewegende geschichte von adn ist ein
weiterer mosaikstein im bild vor
australien
[Musik]
nach 12 300 kilometer ist jetzt fertig
vor zwei wochen bin mit meinem team in
rüti zh im outback statt
hongkong
bauen sich verzählt
ich bin sehr schmal in australien und
tabelle wiederfinden was an optik
dreimal so glücklich wie im locken
[Musik]
mancher kann erklärt warum ich mit ihrer
liegenschaft abgesteckt
[Musik]
für manche kann erklärt warum ich mit
ihrem lebensmotto
und ich kann mancher klein erklärt bei
mir gezeigt hat dass man das glück in
kleine sache
[Musik]
sind manche australier glücklicher als
wir in der schweiz
nein ich glaube nicht mehrere bieter die
reisenden von bord
horizont
und ich weiß jetzt wird offenheit und
erneut vereisen gewinn chance der fahrt
vom eigenen lucky country 9 cent
[Musik]
12 1378 km australien mit globetrotter
dem spezialist für massgeschneiderte
wald mit globetrotter